[Music]
hi there I'm Seth Juarez and I'm here
for the Microsoft research faculty
summit 2017 where the theme is the edge
of AI and I have a couple of guests so
tell us who you are and what you do my
friends we'll start with you I name is
Manish Malik I'm obliged scientists that
relevant in AI team of bang fantastic
and you sir and I'm millage beard a
program manager on the relevance and AIT
fantastic so what do you do in general
how do you help us find things better
why don't we start with you buddy well
that's what we're going to talk about
today working on a project called
infobox ok which is a conversational Q&A
system which really tries to understand
the conversation and tries to answer the
questions for the info seeking questions
that users are asking I see is why is
that such a huge challenge I'm trying to
understand because I can go on to being
and type some crazy query and then I get
a thousand things and then I can search
through and get the answer how are we
making this better so you know
traditional search indexes the web and
you try to rank all the documents that
are there and then you try to find the
best 10 documents to answer your
question and then you have to basically
go into each one of them try to find the
information which is a pretty arduous
task of this paradigm actually breaks
down on mobile because you have a tiny
screen you know try looking at this long
document and trying to find the
information the smart speakers they
don't even have any screen so how do you
even get to those blue links to get the
answers that you need that's where this
byline becomes very important so what we
keep talking about this this new
paradigm why don't you describe that
paradigm for those that are watching so
we can get a sense for what are we
actually doing yeah so what we've
noticing Seth is in this revolution of
AI at this time people want to be able
to talk to machines and people expect
machines to be able to understand the
conversation
understand the context behind the
questions and get the answers directly
without having to read a lot of
documents that the traditional search
engines provided
Nilesh talked about the speakers you
know there's a lot of devices that are
coming to the market where there are no
screens and therefore we have no other
option but to answer the questions
directly think about a user that is that
wants to travel to Singapore and if they
say you know Singapore history and
you're in the current system today
they'll have to read documents or to
understand the history and if they have
more questions like what is their
religion what is the ethnicity what is
the area and population in the
traditional search engines they'll have
to repeat Singapore all the time
repeat the context of Singapore all the
time and we're trying to solve that
problem here and we are trying to
basically answer the questions directly
we feel that if we can save users time
this will not just make search truly
useful it will also make the air
revolution stronger and make you know
search lot more intelligent actually so
the less what does this actually look
like in practice if I have a user that's
using this new paradigm what would that
look like they have something to show us
yes perfect I'll actually I'll show you
a quick demo of the Bing info bot okay
which is the AI powered bot that we have
so today if you go to Bing search engine
type in Singapore history as Manish
mentioned you get a tiny piece of
snippet they're talking about the
history but you have an option to
actually check with the Bing info bot to
find more information I see so this is
literally you are talking to the
computer and asking questions directly
yes I was a little confused as usually I
was like usually we type something in
and then we get an answer and I was
thinking maybe there was more refined
way of searching but you're saying talk
to the thing directly yes okay looks
like in this case it's you're going to
message to the thing directly because
it's a check bot aha and so in this case
you know since the bot already knows my
context I don't have to keep typing the
long queries here I can just say hey
what about the ethnicity
and you know actually Bing is actually
going back to Wikipedia billions of
documents trying to find the right
information for you and you have the
information snippet right there oh I see
so what you're saying then is that when
I'm searching for something instead of
typing Singapore and then typing
Singapore Agnetha T Singapore history
Singapore population the bot already
understands a lot of the context that
were in and then it's able to answer
those further queries not only that it
understands the context but it goes one
step further you can do natural language
based queries because suppose I do its
religions now that I know about
Singapore ethnicity I want to really see
which religions are practiced so let me
show you a couple of demo queries here
we are actually finding the information
and giving you the information that
Singapore has actually ten religions
that they practice over there also and
if I say you know is English spoken
there because I want to know before I
visit that contribute whether I need to
learn some new language or I can
converse in English so I can get this
information the bot understands the
natural language semantics of this and
you get a perfect answer Singapore
English is the English language spoken
in Singapore so this is I mean this
feels natural and the demo is so
unsurprising because it feels like
you're talking to a human but in in the
back end there's there's a fair amount
of AI that's happening yes because I
studied some NLP and question-answer
systems are very difficult to do
properly can you tell us a little bit
about the AI that was involved why don't
you tell us what that Manish how what if
some of the AI it was involved yeah so
let me show you the the next set of demo
and I'll highlight what we are building
into that so if you go up there
Nilesh to the questions yeah this is
good to the arm so the question is is
rattlesnake venomous and you know of
course we are able to extract the
answers but look at the highlighting so
what we are doing is really reading
comprehension we are
first extracting the passages or pieces
of information from the documents that
contain the answer but but that's just
the first step the record the second
step of reading comprehension is we are
then extracting the specific answer from
that passage and highlighting it right
here so we can say the answer to the
question is rattlesnake venomous we are
highlighting the specific answer if you
go down you will see the next question
being is king cobra venomous and here we
are actually building an inference model
which is not just extracting the answer
but really able to infer the answer and
again going back to the point of saving
users time so here the you will see yes
at the top and that's coming from our
inference model and we are now saying
that yes based off of the information we
found in the document but the model is
able to really infer that knowledge and
answer the question directly right there
which is more next level because it's I
mean it's pretty good feed to be able to
look across the documents that are
accessible to being to answer a question
and then highlight where the answer is
but then to go further and say yeah and
here's our evidence is pretty amazing
yeah yeah and going back to that point
because it's a it's a hard problem look
at the third example it's Gordon garter
snake venomous and in this example you
know although we have the answer the
answer is not very straightforward right
it's not a yes/no type of an answer
because the the passage is saying that
although common garter snakes are not
considered venomous they have a gland
which produces some venom right so it's
not you know it's not very obvious and
our models can now really understand a
you know how they infer knowledge from
the pieces of text for a query to answer
the question when to answer the question
directly or show the passage and you
know there are several parts of AI that
has gone into building our system if you
think about conversational Q&A there are
four big pieces one how do you
understand the conversation right which
is the case of sing up
or history and ethnicity we need to
determine whether that this question
requires context from previous questions
or not and the second is if it does how
do you date the context and understand
the question right so what is that what
does that look like like for example if
I'm going to ask a random question to
the bot like who invented the printing
press how old was he when he died is
there some kind of stack that's being
generated in order to remember who that
he is now how do you do that it's a good
question so there are three parts of
that system the first part is restore
context which is we call context as
previous questions and answers that we
gave the user so the questions that user
that you asked and the answers we
provided in that session so that's our
first part second part is our B model
which which is an RNN it can take the
context and the current question and
reformulate the current question to make
it fully independent and the third part
is once you have reformulated into you
know multiple possible options you know
replacing he with let's say the person
exactly the person that being talked
about how do you know that usually
formulated correctly because there could
be several different options right so
that's our third part that's sort of
meat and potatoes for what we do in
relevance and we are now we look at the
post web signals to really figure out
how do you pick the reformulation that
makes the most sense so it looks like
the three-step process is number one you
need to get the question out then you
person you know what the question is
then if there's any indirect object
pronouns for example you need to replace
them I need to replace them an
intelligent way I'm assuming you'll have
multiple candidates does that happen and
then once you use your inference engine
to find out then you go and answer the
question like you did fry a step there
you have to extract the entities and
concepts from the questions right and so
that's where also there's a lot of work
that has gone in the big stack so what
what does that what does that look like
is first of all being has got to be this
tremendous area of information where you
could get all this data out of but
you have also the riches of data that
you have to search through but it's
unclear to me like how you're using
being to answer the question and then
what are you doing with the question
cells because you have to there's a lot
of understanding in the questions right
one still absolutely absolutely so there
are several parts of this system where
we are truly leveraging pain but we're
also building some really amazing piece
of technology to solve the problems so
let me explain the first piece is the
conversational understanding given a
context how do you understand the
question as simple as that it sounds
pretty simple but there are a lot of
models that are being used and we use
Bing stack to the fullest in in this
area for example if the question is if
the question you said you know who acted
in Star Wars Episode five and the next
question is who directed it or when was
he born right so there are lot of
pronouns in these second questions and
these are very easier easy cases because
when there is pronoun you could make the
argument that the pronoun to be resolved
to the context that was there earlier so
we have you know coreference resolution
models we have deep models trained using
a lot of training data that can take the
context from previous questions and
resolve the current question to
understand the question better but
that's just the first part you know once
you understand the question better the
next big part is how do you retrieve the
answer right so we for that as well we
fully leverage bank so we get the
results Bing today is already very good
at saying what documents are good
documents for a question right but what
we do on top of it
is we break down the document barriers
we break it down into pieces of
information that those documents contain
and then rank those pieces of
information
let's make it simple call it a passage
so a document can have different
passages we rank the passages we pick
the best passage
so that's where we use being a lot but
then very next step is once you have the
passage how do you extract the specific
answer and that's really reading
comprehension and we've built attention
models that can you know again trained
on a lot and a lot of training data to
given a question and a passage extract
the appropriate answer and the last step
which is also very important is once you
have extracted the answer for a question
how do you do machine writing how do you
say it in a very natural language way so
that the users can trust the answer that
you've provided for example if the
question is what is the net worth of
Bill Gates and if a machine just blurts
out an answer which is 300 billion
dollars you know you might be wondering
if once that really that really Bill
Gates or was that the other question
exactly and then what we're doing is
we're building a model that can machine
write which can take the question and
the answer and convert it into a very
natural language response can say
something like according to this website
I found that Bill Gates net worth is 320
billion dollars and that is a much
natural response that users can
understand they know the source of where
the information came from and they know
that you know they know something that
they can trust and that's I mean that's
pretty amazing right because what you've
done essentially is you've taken what
being bigs really good at returning
documents you've actually narrowed it
down to being returning passages and
then there's using your machine learning
models to infer the proper answer with
the correct context is that about the
sum of it yes yes and you do this at a
web scale right that is where the bings
strengths in dealing with the entire
internet comes into play this is a very
generic technology that we are building
so you know it's not really specific to
only one type of document it's a it's a
general models that we are building and
that can be leveraged across the
internet so if this is something that's
available now that for example let's
just say I want to open a
home-improvement store and I want my bot
to be able to answer stuff based upon
stuff on my own website is that
something that can be done it could be
absolutely done
it's just that we have to enable it for
that website we have the information
about that website if it is a public
domain website we have that information
it could be very easily turned on from
our side to answer those questions based
on that our website so that's the beauty
of it we can body by the entire web
without end or the webmaster is having
to do anything with that information is
already there we can do machine grading
comp engine and machine writing on top
of it and give you the answers that you
need so at anytime I could have anyone
chat up my website and be like hey so
tell me about your Terms of Service how
long do I have to block then from this
particular type of technology the bot
will be able to answer succinctly and
give you the passage as well that's
great that's that's pretty amazing so
when will this type of stuff be
available so we are heavily
experimenting right now um you know in
some sense we're really truly creating a
new category of product a new direction
of where we want the search to go we
want search to become truly intelligent
truly useful
we want you to save users time and that
takes a lot of iterations we are as I
said experimenting a lot you know
tweaking the experience understanding
how users are reacting and what's
working and what's not but you know and
as soon as we get to a point where we
feel pretty good about how users are
behaving and what information we are
providing and whether they're liking it
or not we'll relieve it it might be
sooner than you think that's amazing I'm
excited for one day I'm going to have my
own shop and I'm going to just ask my
computer tell me how do I make my own
robot and then your robot is going to
tell me how to make a robot and we will
have robot inception thank so much money
you shouldn't allow for spending some
time with us how to make search more
intuitive it's been awesome thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time
thank you thanks
you
[Music]